enfin pour nous il ya un vrai sujet ce
qu'on voit se dessiner c'est la
recherche d'une majorité alternative
faut pas être naïf non plus chez nous
lui dit au nouveau au niveau national a
manifestement vocation à disparaître
c'est jean christophe lagarde qui le dit
donc on va avoir la création d'un
nouveau parti politique avec qui les
constructif on n'en sait rien ici au
sénat le futur groupe centriste que fera
t-il avec le rds eu avec en marche on
voit bien que ces gens là cherchent
effectivement une majorité alternative
donc ça c'est un véritable enjeu pour
nous et voilà pourquoi je souhaite que
le groupe des républicains reviennent
plutôt renforcé par rapport à la
situation actuelle
parce que nous pèserons effectivement
moi je pense je souhaite vivement que
gérard larcher continuer à présider le
sénat
on voit bien que d'autres essayent de
rechercher d'autres solutions il est là
l'enjeu principal
après on verra les politiques que nous
soutiendrons est d'abord un enjeu de
pouvoir et chez en marche aussi bien que
chez certains centristes et au rdse on
voit bien qu'il ya une volonté de
trouver une autre solution